it's great to be joined today by David
Patrick Eric OHS who's the author of war
in 140 characters how social media is
reshaping conflict in the 21st century
you know David we were just speaking
earlier on the program about how if we
had here in the United States the sort
of current circumstances with our
president except in the era of Richard
Nixon lacking the social media presence
that we have and in a very very
different media environment that we
might be seeing a completely different
progression of these sort of
investigations that are currently taking
place in two possible misdeeds by our by
our president do you agree that the the
sort of scope and magnitude with which
social media has changed the sort of
news cycle and political dialogue is is
that significant is that is that an
overstatement to some degree no look I
mean we have we caught between two
stools here on the one hand things are
different on the other hand we don't
want to say that everything is
unprecedented well certainly you know in
the a days of social media Nixon would
have gone down a lot quicker than he did
having said that at the same time we are
in the social media age and Donald Trump
is still in power
oh well over a year after he took office
I'd like to talk a little bit about the
the way in which narratives sort of
start to become built up and that very
often the narrative actually sort of
supersedes or makes irrelevant any
individual fact or story and we've sort
of seen that very very effectively
carried out at least in the context of
this investigation that we're seeing
into Donald Trump the sort of general
narrative of there is a biased
investigation being trumped up by the so
called fake news and social media has
been incredibly effective at furthering
that narrative can you talk a little bit
about that sort of departure or
disconnect that can start to exist
between the facts of any individual
story and event and these overarching
narratives which seem to actually be
much more powerful in some cases
absolutely look what do you have to
understand is social media is geared
toward the promulgation of narratives
and it is geared away from nuance the
inherent structure of social media
platforms think of a tweet
okay now you can say 280 characters
instead of 140 but at the end of the day
is geared toward sensationalism geared
towards virality
the truth is always more nuanced it's
always on the one hand and on the other
and no one wants to read that and the
inherent structure of social media is
geared away from that at the same time
we have a vulcanization you know we all
know about the algorithms that feed us
content that we think that account
claice and we think we'll like so it
feeds us with content that we like and
it reaffirms our own prejudices that way
there is a balkanization now 20 years
ago you could have been all 4050 years
ago when Nixon was in power you could
have been Pro Nix and antonakes but you
still would have watched cable neo
Network News state TV you would have
seen the same images now depending on
who your friend who you follow what
narratives you believe or choose to
believe you can have your own reality
created for you you know on social media
which is where we get most of our news
now and what this means is that someone
who disagrees with you isn't merely
wrong they're evil they're a liar and
this creates greater mistrust great
hatred and greater reactivation of
prejudice is it useful to you know as I
hear you describe that is it even useful
to try to measure out the sort of net
impact of these changes because there
are those who say well on the sort of on
the plus side there's so much more
access much more quickly with fewer
gatekeepers to information that never
would have been accessible before social
media before the modern modern modern
news sort of paradigm on the other hand
you have the creation of the echo
chambers and the filter bubbles as a
result of the algorithms that you're
describing is it even a useful
experiment to think about in the net are
we better off or worse off or is that
sort of the wrong way to think about it
look I mean the thing is I mean it's
hard to quantify but actually I would
say at the moment it's probably a net
loss you know I'll say the story of
social media is the story of the rise
and fall of hope in the beginning we
were told give a man or woman access to
the Internet and it will set them free
and for a while and to a degree it does
we call this now cyber utopianism you
know for a while it will benefit the
downtrodden it will give a voice to the
voices but in the end the tools used by
media press will always become too
used by the oppressor and when they do
it properly and when they do it well as
in the case of Russia you see the
results which can be for everywhere from
Ukraine to the US presidential election
they can be catastrophic yeah I mean I
think that that that's sort of the
direction I wanted to go next which is
there was this idea of social media and
the Internet as a democratizing force an
objectively democratizing force a sort
of transfer of power from the huge
corporate media institutions to
individuals networks of individuals
small groups independent media but to
the extent that that happened initially
it seems that in the long run those big
players will take control back by being
able to just funnel more money into
those new platforms to some degree
absolutely look what's gonna have to
change and you know the big change that
we've seen is the difference the shift
in power between hierarchies and
networks hierarchies and the citizens
and individual networks as individuals
and networks of individuals now what
we're seeing funnily enough and the Alec
Ross was the one who was Secretary of
innovation to Hillary Clinton when she
was Secretary of State he told me about
this shift he's absolutely right
but what we're seeing is the hierarchies
employing the power of networks and that
means Russia in the end setting up these
troll farms creating networks of
propagandists it is true the patter has
gone from you know it has this fuse from
nation-states from big governments from
big corporations to networks of
individuals and the smart players like
Russia are creating their own networks
of bad actors in response we saw this
with Cambridge analytic occur as well
the good guys working in bureaucracies
like the State Department where every
decision has to go up the chain of
command so a risk-averse who are slow
who are bloated we are behind we are
losing and there is another point here
is that we are constrained by deep
diplomatic and democratic norms that
provide actors like Putin or not if you
tried to set up a troll farm in New York
give it a month the New York Times would
expose it the troll farm in San
Petersburg is I mean it's both countless
times not at least in my book but at the
end of the day Putin is not accountable
to the press he's not accountable to his
people so we are behind the curve David
is there any practice
all difference when you talk about you
know a legacy media company using the
bully pulpit to include or exclude
whatever they want from from the
narrative so to speak and that power
being transferred to a company like
Facebook through its algorithm or Google
through search results is it just two
sides of the same coin or is there any
practical difference there's a huge
practical difference in that the power
of the algorithm and the network and the
platform is far greater than that the
New York Times the New York Times is now
he's now tirely reliant not entirely but
is hugely relying on Facebook to get
into the content now they're together
they're thick practically yes there is
one of power and the power is of a
different order of magnitude I use that
expression specifically and carefully
what is the what's the solution to this
if there is one I mean in other words
what what is it that you propose or that
we should be considering as a way that I
think this power back yeah hey look I
hey everyone said this but look you know
at every stage in history of the
advancement of information technology
being the printing press and the
expansion of TV and radio we have seen a
subsequent period of instability this is
what we're in now we're still in the
Wild West days of social media this new
information technologies I think it's
gonna get a lot worse before he gets
better but I think at some point you
know the government is gonna have to
step in some kind of regulation or
preferably legislation is gonna have to
come in and I think we're gonna have to
do practical things like we're gonna
have to start putting social media
literacy on school curriculums we have
to start getting people educated and at
some point the government is gonna have
to step in because self policing is not
work are you of the mindset as I am and
I'd be curious to hear based on what
you've written in the book that any sort
of government approved list or
government rankings of media outlets is
inherently very dangerous yes it is
dangerous this is the problem look we
just fundamentally don't know
now look social media companies have a
default free speech libertarian model
and that is absolutely correct
but there is a difference between free
speech which is right and legal and
incitement to violence which is illegal
I give you honestly five minutes you'll
find that sort of stuff on any platform
you go on this sort of stuff needs to be
cut out the problem
it is not illegal to lie you know that's
not a crime nor should it be a crime we
start me to making it illegal to lie
then we've got big problems so you know
it is an incredibly complex problem both
practically and philosophically how do
you do it the point is I think what you
have to do is set clear boundaries look
Simon to violence is clear they should
not be jihadist content that is getting
people to go to Syria on Facebook and
Twitter and there is so stuff like that
you find people heavily you hit them
where it hurts which is always in the
wallet you start with stuff like that
ranking things saying what's good what's
bad we get into realms of subjectivity
and whose truth is right and Beyond I
mean beyond facts I mean you know I mean
we can't start saying well if you're a
conservative you look at this you're a
liberal you're that so I agree it's
fundamentally dangerous but there are
some initial practical steps that can be
taken and need to be taken David I know
you've got limited time last thing I
wanted to touch on is you mentioned how
things are very very different in Russia
for example with regards to something
like a troll farm among the sort of
Western democracies do you see that
there are philosophical differences in
terms of how different countries would
be inclined to deal with this that are
important or do you feel that the
Western democracies are more or less on
the same page with this issue
look there's a fundamental I mean look
we're more or less on the same page and
I've done work in this area in council
tips information but you know there is a
difference between you know I think that
we're gonna see an increasingly a
European Internet and an American
internet America has the First Amendment
we obviously have free speech in Europe
as well but there is more appetite here
to regulate there is more appetite to
legislate than in the US so I think
we're broadly on the same page we're all
you know Western democracies but I think
you're gonna see slightly slightly
tightening of the Internet in Europe as
opposed to the US
David Pedro Caracol so the book is war
in 140 characters I really appreciate
you making time for us today thank you
for inviting me thank you